Now, ASAPSCIENCE offers you periodic table elements.
There are hydrogen then helium, then lithium, beryllium,
Boron and carbon are everywhere,
Nitrogen fills the air.
With oxygen so you can breathe,
The fluorine of your beautiful teeth,
Neon to light up ads,
Sodium for saline times.
magnesium,
Aluminum, Silicone.
Phosphorus!
Then sulfur, chlorine, and argon.
Potassium!
And calcium becomes even stronger.
Scandium!
Titanium, vanadium, chromium, manganese!
This is a periodic table, inactive inert gases, halogens and alkali react strongly!
Every time we see new exterior casings
While electrons are added, when moving to the right.
The iron is 26.
Then cobalt, the nickel from which you get money.
Copper, zinc, and gallium.
Germanium and arsenic!
Selenium and bromine, while the krypton helps to illuminate your room.
Rubidium and strontium then itrium, zirconium
Niobium!
Molybdenum.
Technetium.
Routine!
Rhodium and Palladium.
Silverware, then cadmium and indium
Tin cans!
Antimony!
Then telorium, iodine, xenon and then cesium and ...
Barium is 56, this is where the table is divided into.
Where the lanthanides begin.
Lanthanum, cerium, and percidium.
Neodymium next to Promethium then 62.
Samarium, europium, gadolinium, terbium, dysprosium, holium, erbium, tholium, erythropium, luteium.
Hafnium, Tantalum, Tungsten and then we are in for rhenium, ammonium and iridium.
Platinum and gold make you rich until you get old.
Mercury, tells you when the weather is very cold.
Thallium!
Lead and then bismuth to your belly.
Polonium!
That the statins would not be delicious.
Radon gas, and French continue for some time.
Radium!
Then actinides at 89!
This is a periodic table, stable inert gases, halogens and alkali react strongly!
Each period we will see new outer casings, while the electrons rotate to the right.
Actinium, thorium, protactinium.
Uranium, neptunium and plutonium.
Emerysium, korium, percyllium, californium,
Fermium, mandelivium, noblium, lorancium, Rutherfordium, dibenium, cyprogium, borium, calcium, maitnarium, darmstadt,
Reuentegenium, Copernicium.
Anon Triom!
Flervium.
Anon Pentium, Livermorium.
Anon Septium, Anon Octium.
Then we finish!
Did you like this song?
Make sure you have it on your iTunes and BandCamp.
Links in description.
And subscribe to great science fiction weekly.